it's just totally new and amazing
Priyanka Chopra Jonah's glowing as new
hubby showed his support at the premiere
of her new film isn't it romantic are
you feeling what I'm feeling so here we
are the big premiere how does it feel to
be called mrs. Priyanka Chopra Jonas
that's how you've been announced I was
just telling rebel that and we both
started laughing cuz it's so different
and especially like my work atmosphere
so like weird but fun and like just
having Nick with me I've never done this
with someone with me you know it's just
all really new and amazing how does it
feel to have his support um it's great
in fact we were talking about it in the
car like it's it's just it's so amazing
to have someone out there rooting for
you and you know that that's your
partner and they're always on your team
and whatever happens that's your person
and there's such an amazing security and
that I loved it I know he was at that
Gulf German here he hauled but to get
over for you girl
he didn't list is he missed the team
picture too but so bad and they won they
won what is the best part of married
life for you I think just the the safety
and the consistency of it just knowing
that whatever happens you're not in it
alone and there's such a beauty to that
Valentine's Day plans for you guys the
movies coming out yeah we were not even
supposed to be in the same city together
but we're both in London now
coincidentally so yeah it should be
should be special now we know Liam's not
here tonight but Miley came supporting
Leah I know isn't that amazing if you
would Nick laughed about that it's a
little small world that the two of them
at this movie with even with you guys I
know I feel like it's the movie actually
that did that that even I got married
and even I was single at that time when
I was filming this movie but we both got
married during amazing wasn't it gonna
feel watching you sing on screen I don't
know but I'll be embarrassed
[Music]